does money make you happy how much space
is too much space
and can a hundred thousand square feet
of prime la real estate
fill up the void in a broken man's heart
today
we're gonna be answering those questions
thanks to a new side of youtube i
recently discovered
which i like to call ultra rich flex
youtube and they're gonna be blessing us
poor people today i mean i know i know i
got the lambo in the back
for these people a lamborghini is like a
cardboard box
okay it's nothing to them these people
are ridiculous
and today they're gonna be blessing us
look with a feature-length documentary
called
the biggest and most expensive house in
the world
which they are humbly calling the one
now if you're interested in this i
encourage you to go watch the whole
thing because i'm just going to be
cherry picking the best little bits uh
because normally i'm not interested in
this kind of stuff i mean
it's fine if you're into it but for me
luxury for the sake of luxury isn't my
style but the reason
this video interests me and the reason
i'm bringing it before you today
is number one listen we've been talking
about too many dark things
pumping dumps scams whatever it's nice
to take a little bit of a pause
but secondly this video is so much more
than it appears under the surface it is
like
the the iceberg of videos it appears to
be a luxury video
about a luxury house but in fact under
the surface
it's like a mini documentary on the
hollowness of wealth
the insanity of obsession a testament to
just how out of touch
you can get with regular human beings
it's incredible
okay it's it's a journey that's all i
can say and before we embark on it let
me just introduce you real quick
to the main characters of our saga
the first is this designer niall niamey
he's the developer of
the one he's a complete psychopath
the second one though is our host
producer michael who's one of the
biggest
ultra rich content creators now i'm not
i don't want to bias you anymore so
without further ado
put these on real quick droning over
miami let's go
it is the most epic of epic videos
we are at the largest
house in the urban world when i say the
largest
it is a hundred and five thousand square
feet
it is called the one and what gets
better than that we
are with the one and only nile who
is the visionary behind this he built
this and he is just
an incredible guy and he's going to show
us around this house
that no cameras have seen this house
before in its entirety ever ever ever is
that correct that's right
so it starts out the tour starts off
fine but pretty quickly it's clear that
things start to go off the rails the
type of person to build this house is
not going to be stable
this office is the only room in the
house the house is surrounded by water
so we have little moats and we have a
total of seven water features and
swimming pools combined
but this office you'll see every single
wall in this office touches water so
it's like it's floating this is just
incredible look at the height of this
i'm six foot two
one small question why i feel like
you could fit a small crane in there and
i'm not talking about the bird
these are supposed to be drawers how do
you get there
with the cherry picker it's it's
impossible to put anything in those
shelves
i think this is the best moment where
you realize these people are on one
talk to you guys about that because it's
something close to me they're taking us
to a glass statue and then
off hand he says this um this is a moat
and the reason that we did a moat here
let me stop you right there
there is no reason to do a moat at first
i love how he's like hey we're gonna go
see this oh by the way there's the moat
and then he tries to justify like
there's any good reason forever
for emote but besides to defend you know
some castle structure from
invading troops so below we have
probably the world's most expensive
running track
because you can't run in bel air because
there's no sidewalk so now you can run
from here all the way to where the front
door is does anybody ever stop in these
projects and go
but why the property is like a hundred
thousand square feet
i feel like running from one bedroom to
another is enough of a workout are you
choking me
this is going to be a first i never walk
on grass
like usually you watch videos because
it's like relatable i have to imagine
nobody's watching this and thinking yeah
that's me
this is real grass and i'm gonna walk on
it what congratulations michael
welcome to the team i guess this artist
was nice enough to make this for us
and because they wanted to be involved
in the one but it's turned into
something so much more because
my ex-wife i i'm just getting divorced
unfortunately oh
okay that's very sorry to hear that it
was a whirlwind relationship i met her
during coven and it
it didn't work out matter married her
and divorced her
during covet okay weird thing to bring
up when you're bragging about the one
okay bad joke is that why she didn't go
with you because she never felt like she
was the one
hey you know what i'll i'll see myself
out for that one
kidding guys i would never leave you in
the middle of our show
excuse me go ahead sorry sorry to
interrupt you there bud but this is a
charity that we have called wings of
angels and this is going to help
children in third world countries it's
not through the arts
because what what are you going to send
him a picture you sent him a little
postcard hey look how sick my house is
this artist was nice enough to make this
for us
she she came from a very tough life in
cordoba
and she wants to be part of the
solution of changing the world and one
of the ways we're gonna do this here
is through this charity i i guess he's
talking about like a real charity but
you keep
touching the sculpture and it makes me
think that you think that the sculpture
is gonna
like save kids with the arts and by the
way i don't think their problem is not
enough arts i think their problem is
food i'm not trying to hate on this
guy's charity thing i just think it's
funny that he thinks this sculpture is
going to change the world
this is a elevator a machine elevator i
think there's six elevators
he's like that's like the lamest one
actually keep it moving
we've got six of them dime a dozen year
in
the one here you know i'm i'm a big
developer i i
have built a lot of houses no houses
like this but i've learned over time
that we really need to start
sustaining and trying to do things where
we don't just waste
this man has built one of the most
opulent
wasteful properties in the entire world
and then he unironically because you can
feel it can't you that he believes this
he unironically
like is trying to say to this guy he's
delivering the property to like hey man
really learned how to not be wasteful
the irony hurts so this is one thing
that that we found
all of my flowers are artificial but you
can never tell
right i hate this man i really do this
is
where it turns for me from like hey this
guy's like it's funny how out of touch
to like oh
i hate you though oh my gosh
you're saving the world through
artificial flowers
in the most wasteful property of all
time it could be an
apple headquarters the size of this
building
and it's for one person there couldn't
be a more wasteful thing
on earth and this guy's trying to tell
you learned a lot about you know
uh the green world it's like when you
know somebody's flying a private jet and
they're lecturing you about recycling
they're like hey you gotta recycle those
aluminum cans it's like you jackass
okay we see what you're doing coffee tea
anything you want but the cool thing
about
it is this is the setup here so it holds
the milk and keeps it cold so you don't
have to fill the milk up like in the
melees
and then it grinds it fresh so this does
everything you don't have to descale you
want to do anything you just this is the
first part of the house where i'm kind
of like
i kind of want that can we start a
gofundme for me guys
touch on your phone cappuccino and other
than having a cup come up
it does it all guess where we saw one of
these michael where
in your other house oh yeah in your oh
yeah this i forgot about this part
tiny little 18 000 foot house that was
65 million bucks
which one was that which did you go to
which
18 million dollar house are you talking
about referring to with that super
specific cappuccino machine i've got 12
of them
and just wait because it gets so much
worse
how much of the house would you say this
is nile percentage-wise that we're
looking at
15 10.
so look look at the running track
oh you weren't kidding no that's a real
running track yeah
yeah you can watch the moment he
realizes this
oh wait rich people don't run why would
you want to run
on a track where you can look down and
see your kind of hideous
disgusting poor neighbors you don't want
to see that right
so they take us to the nightclub i would
say that probably the part that the
most people have been talking about
about this house tour though is this
weird moment i know and unfortunately in
l.a i know
a lot of the dudes are scumbags here and
i'm going to change that i'm going to
turn all the dudes into good
people how are you going to do that one
of the things i'm going to do is i'm
going to set them on their feet so check
out what i did in here
plates right here that's for a monitor
right
and then if you come into the his side
so he puts a monitor in the girls side
can you believe these are the these are
the urinals
and i'm gonna have cameras here looking
at the guys
you're gonna have cameras me too hey me
too this man right now
i'm just not sure the logic tracks here
this guy says hey i'm gonna save the
dudes in la from being total
dirtbag scumbags i'm tired of it how are
you gonna do that
i'm gonna spy on people's uh genitals
without their consent
that's hey
oh man are you guys not entertained this
is this is not your average
luxury tour guys we are witnessing a
special breed
of human who has transcended social cues
who has transcended self-awareness and
becomes something entirely the type of
man
who knows how to set men right by
peeking on their
private parts i guess little dick camera
is what it is
camera's looking at the guys putting the
image in the girls bathroom
out of the box thinking that's adorable
i have to say
the approach of let's stop guys by being
creepy
by being even creepier it is out of the
box
i'm just not sure how that's going to
work for you chief now with all these
beautiful moments of these people being
out of touch whatever i think it's
finally time to in a tour prematurely
you can go watch the full thing on their
youtube channel
and talk about the true insanity because
if you thought they're just walking you
through the house was crazy
there's an even better video called the
one its vision and future
explained which is a video about the
house and like what it's built for
and this is what really blew my mind
about realizing oh
these people need professional help like
it is beyond a youtube video to help
these people
yeah they're asking like what's your
favorite part of this house the designer
is going to answer
answer now miami miami and
you said something like what we can do
with the house
what did you mean tell everybody well i
think
that i have something very very exciting
and i believe
that i don't have this by chance the
house
is called the one bel-air and my show is
called
the one and between those two i think
that
we have the ability to really change the
world in a
very positive way when you say change
the world in a positive way
how does this house change the world
this is the first
great question by producer michael uh so
far it's just been like clapping this
guy in the back
for building this completely ridiculous
house nobody needs this
and actually i heard that this guy is
having a hard time selling it because
of basically precisely that problem so
then this guy goes oh it's going to
change the world
so how i i i i will explain so
because of covet all of the
venues around the world have been either
shut down or dramatically
altered there is nowhere in the world
really where you can go
for a venue like you used to have like
a big boxing match or the academy awards
if you're asking yourself is he going
where i think he's going with this
because if he is
he's the worst human on the planet the
answer is yes to
all of the grammys or anything else that
required a large crowd to gather at
staples center or mgm
or caesars palace or any of these other
places but we have it now
because this house has the ability
to hold 900 people in
a safe coveted environment let's give it
up guys
we the the world was suffering because
nobody could meet together and this guy
spent like 100 million dollars 500
million dollars building something that
could seat
900 people this guy's like hey the world
has a problem
no one can commute because of coven so i
spent 10 years building this thing that
can make 900 rich people's life slightly
better
because by you're not inviting poor
people right look i love how this guy's
like hey
i'm doing charities for like like poor
people and then you find out that
actually the house
is of course just for rich people to go
from their mansion to the giga mansion
and what is being created for this house
is a show
that is a show that everyone will want
to watch and identify with
because it stars me nobody identifies
with this or you
and i live in the house with people that
i love we do
crazy things and have crazy parties but
we also
help the world in so many different ways
this is this is great
i'm sure this is how the kardashians
feel too they're like we're doing the
world a service
we're changing the world how will people
get to watch us live a great life
it's like that doesn't that doesn't
change my life
but what would change like you know
third world country people's life
is not you building a a mansion in the
most
wealthy part of the world it's you
may be helping with that money and i'm
not saying this to like
you know shame this guy for spending the
money his money the way he wants to
spend it but you can't pretend you're
helping the world
while not helping the world that's all
i'm saying don't say you're
doing this for charity or the world when
you're just building yourself
a hundred thousand square foot mega giga
mansion
we are creating gigantic boxing matches
right in the grass with the world
championship
boxers that you could ever imagine and
concerts
and anything that you could imagine that
has a pay-per-view event
leading up to the pay-per-view event
will be my show
so the the talent will come through the
lands will be here
because i have a lot of friends who are
billionaires
i have a lot of friends who have more
money than they know what to do with and
you understand
if you have a billion dollars how much
money you're making a year if it's at
five percent
what if you have two billion what if you
have three billion
you could never spend that money well i
have a friend are you lecturing us as
like a multi-millionaire that other
people are being
not being generous with their money and
they're using it for selfish reasons are
you really doing that it's three billion
dollars
and when i was in my house looking up at
the sky saying i didn't have enough
money to buy a cheeseburger
he wouldn't help me
[Laughter]
this okay this is about as relatable as
kanye west being like i'm in debt
nobody's sad for you kanye and nobody's
sad for this guy
it is not because people don't care
about the poor it's because you're not
poor this is a real person who was like
five minutes ago telling us that he's
got you know which multi-million dollar
house are you talking about
a tiny little 18 000 foot house that was
65 million bucks
which one was that which did you go to
he's complaining
about not having money to buy a
cheeseburger i'm sorry it's not gonna
work you have to feel bad for this guy
at a certain level because it's like i
don't know man i
i don't think this guy's happy with his
life and fundamentally that's because
money doesn't buy you happiness and like
this video is just such a beautiful
testament to
there is no such thing as enough because
as soon as he start finishes this
this thing apparently he's gonna you
know try to invest money into
a plane right because you know his house
wasn't enough
i guess he needs to put a plane on it i
am going to buy this plane that i call
the god plane
yeah and that's basically what you're
dealing with i mean this guy is totally
delusional
i think producer michael might be one of
the most sane ones to be honest i've
watched a few of his videos since
this video that we're watching here and
he comes across more as a
collector like an interested collector
like he just wants to show you the cool
stuff he has
rather than somebody who's just doing it
to flex on people
so i would have to say producer michael
even though he doesn't challenge him
very much here
he definitely is a lot more normal and
it seems more well adjusted than anyone
else we're talking about
although i will say the grass comment
was very extra this is going to be a
first i never walk on grass
and yeah at the end of the day like what
do these people have to show for it like
the guy
uh complains multiple times in this
interview about his ex-wife
i just don't think these things make
people happy and i think this show is
like a great
accidental documentary into this i hope
you enjoyed
this different kind of video and um
thanks for watching see you guys the
next one